now this president Trump's UN Ambassador
nikki Haley will resign at the end of
the year the president announced the
move in the Oval Office a short time ago
Haley the former governor of South
Carolina has served in the Trump
administration since it began the
president says she has done a quote
incredible job and he hopes she can
return someday major Garrett is at the
White House major not many people saw
this one coming not at all
the president told reporters just a
couple of moments ago that about six
months ago his UN Ambassador nikki Haley
informed him that by the end of the year
she would leave her post that's
certainly something she kept to herself
and the White House kept on a close hold
as well and the atmospherics the
choreography today designed to look and
make it feel as if this is an amicable
departure for the UN Ambassador who in
the main has supported Trump
administration policies on Iran Syria
North Korea but interestingly has been
more aggressive than the president on
the topic of Russia saying just a couple
of weeks after the president's Helsinki
summit with Vladimir Putin we don't
trust Russia we don't trust Putin we
never will now nikki Haley also told
reporters she's not going to run for any
political office after leaving this post
and that she will campaign for president
Trump whom she said she expects to run
for re-election in 2020 those of us who
remember the 2016 campaign remember
nikki Haley as an early supporter a
Florida Senator Marco Rubio but then
after Trump won the nomination she
became an advocate for the Trump
policies during the general election and
served as the president said admirably
as his UN Ambassador back to you guys
all right major thank you